thank you very much Tony thank you to
our panel I frankly am looking forward
to hearing their remarks today and so
mine are going to be very brief but
thank you to everyone in the audience
this is really a remarkable crowd an
overflow room is always a great thing to
see especially at a time of the year
when people have so much going on with
this place going back to school with
kids back in the classroom this is
really an amazing turnout and frankly a
testament to how seriously we take this
issue here in Connecticut I've chosen to
refocus and reup my work on the issue of
climate change as a new United States
Senator for one simple reason during the
very short time that I have been in
federal public office this now being my
seventh year in those very short seven
years what began as the worst-case
estimates about sea level rise and
temperature rise over the rest of this
century are now the mainstream
scientific estimates in only a half a
decade all of a sudden we have come to a
consensus that some of our worst fears
now may be coming true during that exact
same time that I've been in the house
and in the Senate I've become a father I
have a five-year-old and a one-year-old
at home and I shudder to think about
what this world is going to look like at
the end of this century when I hope that
they may still be living on this earth
if we don't make changes today because
this is one of those issues that if you
don't change habits now the trend lines
may be so locked in that they cannot be
reversed by my children no matter how
well I raise them no matter how smart
they are how prescient they become no
matter how turned on their generation is
to this issue it may be too late and so
that's why so many of us who came to the
house of the Senate maybe five or ten
years ago caring about this issue now
have it at the top of our priority list
because we see a very short time window
in terms of our ability to act and the
reason why we focused here on
connecticut is because just in the last
12 months we have had first
witness to the devastation that climate
change can bring to this state we
probably all remember where we were the
night that storm sandy hit I was at home
in Cheshire our power had gone out we
didn't have a backup generator I had a
little bit of power left on my phone and
I was sitting up with our one lamp in
our bedroom at about the witching hour
of eleven or twelve o'clock locked onto
the small battery power that was sending
me tweets from norwalk and Stanford not
knowing whether or not the world was
ending in those cities not understanding
whether those places would still be
there the next morning we barely
survived sandy and yet the devastation
still totals across the stretch and the
billions we've seen what it can do here
in Connecticut and we know how
vulnerable we are as the panelists will
tell you we are really unique we are a
coastline state where almost all of our
economic assets essentially run right
along the stretch of the coastline the
two major thoroughfares of 95 and the
Amtrak line every major economic hub
save for Hartford along the coastline
some of our biggest economic drivers
like the casinos for instance within a
relative short distance from the coast
storms that used to be happening every
12 months in Connecticut are happening
every six months now just in 10 years
sea levels rising by an inch per decade
for Connecticut's standpoint we don't
survive as a state or an economy if we
don't get this right in the short run
and so that's why we wanted to convene
this group here today to expand upon a
conversation that's happening at
multiple levels so excited to hear about
the announcement that you just heard
about a new climate prediction tool
specifically dedicated to the Northeast
that Yale and the center are going to be
investing in that is something that is
badly badly needed because we are no
longer as interested in simply
addicting how big the next storm is
going to be we need in order to do real
land use planning for instance in this
state amid shrinking resources to know
what's happening in the five and
ten-year time window that's what's
happening here in Connecticut and this
is a focus here on the Northeast but
given the fact that this will be
probably the only two hour time block in
this week last week and the next week
that I won't be thinking about Syria let
me make this contextual for you for a
second because this is about the effects
on the Northeast but from 2006 to 2011
rainfall in Syria fell to below eight
inches per year which is the absolute
minimum level necessary to be able to
kick-out abril agriculture going without
irrigation during that time in order to
make do with less water tens of
thousands of new wells were drilled all
throughout Syria having the effect of
dropping the water table below the level
that any of the pumps could reach
agriculture during that five year period
of time disappeared in many regions of
Syria and in the regions in which it
remained was reduced by about 75 to 85
percent over that time stretch two to
three million of Syria's 10 million
people fell into destitute poverty
bumping up against all of the political
refugees over the last ten years that it
spilled in from Israel and Iraq and
other places there are a lot of reasons
why we're talking about Syria today it's
not just about a massive drought that
was made much worse by temperatures
already increased in Syria and the
region that created a vicious cycle of
evaporation that made this drought worse
than any of the other droughts that it
hit there's a lot of other reasons at
the top of the list still being the
brutal repression of Assad and his
family on the people of that country but
make no mistake the turbulence that we
have seen in Syria and the Middle East
is a consequence of climate change
consequence of droughts that when they
happen today happen harder tougher with
more dire consequences than they ever
did before we are seeing the results of
climate change in the Middle East and
while we may never become that fractious
here we know that if we don't make some
changes here in Connecticut dire times
in a different fashion await us as well
last thing to say is about politics I
don't want to talk too much about
partisan politics here today except to
say that the effort on climate
communication is critical and still at
the top of the list as far as I'm
concerned right now in Washington about
fifty six percent of the House
Republican caucus denies the climate
change exists about sixty percent of the
Senate Republican caucus one hundred
percent of the Republicans that sit on
the Environment Committee in the Senate
our climate deniers as well as 17 of 22
that said in the Science Committee in 22
of 30 that's it on the Energy Committee
if we don't invest in education about
the 99 percent of scientists who tell us
that our actions are contributing to
global warming we can't win this fight
in Washington we can't get anything done
we have to engage in a robust battle to
change public opinion to make sure that
people are sent to Washington that
believe in science again or all of the
work that we are doing on mitigation and
new plans to reduce carbon emissions
aren't going to mean anything that being
said there is some really good news
happening around the globe buried amidst
the talk of Syria at the g20 was a
breakthrough on the issue of hfcs which
are the substitute for the stuff that we
got rid of in the montreal protocols
that was burning a hole through the
ozone layer hfcs the substitute for CFCs
are now one of the most insidious
Climate Pollutants in that they get into
the atmosphere and trap heat at a rate
frankly that is much worse than
traditional carbon dioxide and for the
first time China at the g20
made a commitment to begin a contact
group with the United States to come up
with some new standards to reduce the
usage of hfcs and the other g20 nations
including developing nations like Brazil
and India agreed to a slightly more
beginning step at the same work as well
that's really really good news nations
that we had just a devil of a time
getting to the table to get serious
about this issue now realize that it is
in their interest to be with us today on
Climate Pollutants maybe carbon dioxide
is a tougher nut to crack but if you can
take on some of these short-lived
fast-acting Climate Pollutants things
like hfcs or methane or black carbon we
can get a lot of pretty important work
done so as bad as things may seem in
Washington there are so there is some
good news when it comes to the
international climate change front and
it matters to everybody who lives on
this world but here in Connecticut as
you will hear it likely matters as much
if not more than everywhere else we've
got a fantastic panel here today I'm
eager to hear your questions and your
thoughts as well thank you to the Yale
climate and energy institute for hosting
us here today and I hope we have a great
discussion thank you very much everyone